Bessie's kendall Jenner and Gigi Hadid  might have just shot their most bizarre  photoshoot yet the models pose together  for W magazine's 10th anniversary art  issue it's just a really really great  feeling but we noticed some serious  alterations to Kenji's faces and  physiques Kinney and Gigi looked pretty  normal on the cover sporting identical  dresses in a camping theme shoot except  one thing was missing their knees here's  a closer look at the odd nila shot of  the supermodel pair resembling Barbie  doll legs however it seems this isn't a  photoshop fail the issue is titled  placebo pets where the models are  portrayed as creatures from another  dimension while this might also explain  Kendall and Gigi strange appearances  inside the glossy the supermodel besties  have yet to speak out about the unique  spread that has the internet going nuts  it's not that big of a deal between us  but we think it's pretty awesome  you